This chart appeared in the 2017
President's Commission on Combating
Drug Addiction and the Opioid Crisis
to demonstrate a link between legal
opioids like OxyContin and
overdoses.
One line shows opioid prescriptions
and another the number of people
being admitted to treatment centers
for opioid abuse.
And the third chart two deaths from
opioid overdoses.
It demonstrates absolutely nothing.
By using a chart like this as
evidence that the increase in opioid
prescriptions caused the overdose
crisis. Government officials
committed the most rudimentary
statistical error of all, which is
to assume that correlation proves
causation.
Global avocado production also
climbed in these years.
My age also went up.
Does that mean avocado production in
my age might have something to do
with the increase in overdose
deaths?
No. While it's at least plausible
that an increase in opioid
prescriptions led to an increase in
overdoses, you can't determine
that simply by noting parallel
increases. The purpose of
statistical analysis is to test
our theories and assumptions, and
this chart fails miserably in
that regard.
The way it's drawn in the
Commission's published report also
gives the misimpression that the
rates of increase for these three
lines were about the same.
Actually, all three lines are
measured in different units and the
chart should look more like this.
Another red flag.
This chart doesn't go past 2010,
even though the report came out in
2017.
There's a reason for that.
In the years that followed, the
pattern rapidly reversed, with
opioid prescriptions falling
dramatically while drug related
deaths continued to increase.
The use of charts like this one,
which is part of the government's
failure to correctly understand
and respond to the opioid overdose
crisis, has caused enormous human
suffering. The government has pushed
doctors to severely limit opioid
prescriptions for pain patients
through laws, regulations and the
threat of civil and criminal
penalties.
And today, thousands of Americans
with chronic and debilitating
illnesses are unable to access
drugs that could alleviate their
pain. This chart from the CDC
gives us a clear picture of events.
Drug related deaths involving
commonly prescribed opioids like
hydrocodone and oxycodone,
did rise in the first decade of the
21st century, but then
leveled off for the first
ten years. The increase in overdoses
correlated with increases in the
prescriptions for those
prescriptions filled after 2010
with no reduction in overdoses.
What we did see in 2010 was
an increase in illegal heroin use
and in 2013
and even sharper rise in overdoses
from fentanyl and other synthetic
opioids rarely used in legal
medicine.
This was likely caused by a change
in the business practices of drug
cartels and the fact that fentanyl
is cheaper and easier to smuggle
than heroin.
During this period, fentanyl, which
is more potent than heroin,
became increasingly common as a
heroin booster and substitute.
If heroin were legal, most
of these overdose deaths probably
would not have occurred.
The governments clamp down on
prescription opioids also probably
exacerbated the overdose crisis.
The blockbuster pain drug OxyContin
became available in 1996.
Three years later, we do indeed see
a rise in deaths involving
prescription opioids.
But that does not necessarily mean
those deaths involve people who
obtain prescriptions from doctors.
National survey data from 2013
and 2014 indicated
that most people who misused
prescription pain relievers reported
getting them from a friend or
relative.
Then a quarter said they obtain the
drugs from doctors.
A survey of OxyContin addicted
people entering rehab from 2001
to 2004 found
that 78% had never been
prescribed the medication, and among
the 22% who had been prescribed
OxyContin, nearly all had substance
abuse problems before taking the
drug.
So if they weren't taking OxyContin,
they would likely would have been
taking something else.
The stereotype of a clean living
person getting hooked on opioids,
originally prescribed for pain
and then suffering a fatal or
non-fatal overdose is not common
in the data.
As prescription opioids became
harder to find in the black market,
many non-medical users of these
drugs likely turned to heroin
contaminated with fentanyl, putting
them at a much higher risk of
overdosing.
They were replaced illegally,
produced, reliably dosed
pharmaceuticals with black market
drugs whose potency is highly
variable and unpredictable.
If we widen the time span, we see
that overall drug overdose deaths
have been increasing at a fairly
steady rate since 1979
or 17 years before OxyContin
became available and continuing long
after illegal use of opioids was
severely cut back.
During the same period, we see
parallel increases in deaths from
suicide and alcohol abuse
or so-called deaths of despair.
There have also been steady
increases in diagnoses of
depression.
This suggests that many deaths ruled
accidental overdoses could be
deliberate suicides, or perhaps
they were partially deliberate.
Although this is correlation, not
causation. So we don't know for
sure. The data also suggests that
the underlying cause of the overdose
crisis is more fundamental than
overprescribing of opioids.
Back around 2010, when
opioid prescriptions were still
rising. Alongside overdoses.
It was plausible to investigate a
link, but none of them took the
correct approach, which would be to
compare similar patients, one of
whom got a prescription for opioids
and the other who did not.
Such match pairs shouldn't just be
checked for overdose deaths, which,
after all, affect only 0.04%
of patients, but for overall health
and quality of life.
Instead, researchers compared
unmatched samples of patients, some
of whom received higher doses of
opioids in others.
One influential and heavily cited
study published in 2011
in the Journal of the American
Medical Association, began with
a sample of 750 veterans
health patients who received opioid
prescriptions for pain and later
died of opioid overdoses.
It compared them to a random sample
of 155,000 other
veterans health patients who also
received opioid prescriptions and
didn't die of overdoses.
It found that the high dose opioid
prescriptions were more likely to
lead to fatalities, a finding that
was used to support the CDC
guidelines for strongly discouraging
large doses.
The problem with this study is that
the high dose and low dose patients
differed in many ways.
In particular, the high dose
patients presumably had more severe
pain and more serious medical
issues. They may have also differed
in the type of pain they endured or
the length of time they suffered.
Controls have to match subjects as
closely as possible.
This study did not meet that basic
requirement of good science.
It is plausible that in the 750
patients who overdosed did so for
reasons other than the amount of
opioids they were prescribed for
reasons the study couldn't control
for, 40% have been diagnosed
with substance abuse disorders in
the 12 months before getting an
opioid prescription, 66%
had been diagnosed with a
psychiatric disorder.
A population with these
characteristics is likely to have a
higher than normal frequency of
overdose death with or without legal
opioid prescriptions.
Perhaps most important, the study
ignores the benefits of opioid pain
relief to 155,000
patients who didn't overdose.
Even if taking prescription opioids
does increase the risk of overdose
deaths, but the study doesn't
demonstrate. Many patients would
gladly accept the risk for the
quality of life improvement of
diminished pain.
An influential 2010 study
published in the Annals of Internal
Medicine also attempted to show
that higher prescribed doses of
opioids correlated with a higher
risk of death from overdose.
But within the study group, there
were just six patients who died of
opioid overdoses, fewer
than the number of study authors.
Yet the authors claim statistically
significant results after adjusting
for smoking, depression, substance
abuse, comorbid conditions, pain,
side age, sex, recent sedative,
hypnotic prescription, and recent
initiation of opioid use.
This is absurd.
It would take at least 100 patients
who died to estimate the
adjustments, much less make any
conclusions with statistical
confidence.
The authors even conceded that it
was not established whether their
results were due to patient
differences or direct effect of
higher dose.
In other words, the study
demonstrates nothing. Although they
are more than a decade old, these
studies continue to be cited by
public health officials and
policymakers, including the 2017
President's Commission on Combating
Drug Addiction and the Opioid
crisis, which relied almost
completely on studies published
before 2014, which generally
used data collected before 2011.
Again, there's no mystery as to why,
only by relying on outdated studies
could the prescription opioids cause
the crisis narrative be sustained.
Government officials haven't
reckoned with the abysmal failure of
limiting access to prescription
opioids.
Rather, they've doubled down on the
policy while citing and promoting
statistically flawed studies based
on stale data and promoting
charts that conspicuously cut off
before the data start to undermine
their chosen policy.
No one has yet demonstrated that
patients prescribed opioids are more
likely to suffer overdoses than
match patients who were denied them.
No one has shown that overall
quality of life and life expectancy
are lower for opioid patients.
The first step to arriving at a
serious policy response to the
overdose crisis is to take an honest
look at the problem by using
statistical techniques to gain a
deeper understanding of its root
causes.
Instead, government officials want
us to look at three lines going up
over a set time period.
How long in the past?
And assume that they must have
something to do with each other.